we have reached that part in the program
where an award will be made to one of
five actors who are nominated for acting
in parts that could easily have been
rewritten for me to make the
presentation there is a superb actress
and former Oscar winner who is herself a
nominee again this year she played the
part of Eleanor Roosevelt so
convincingly at Westbrook Pegler now
hates her
here is this greer garson
thank you Bob
because I am acutely and even rather
painfully aware of what this moment
means to a number of you out there in
the auditorium
I will mercifully get to the punt
nominated for the best performance by an
actor our five individually wonderful
actors Trevor Howard in Sons and Lovers
Burt Lancaster in Elmer Gantry Jack
Lemmon in the apartment Laurence Olivier
in the Entertainer and Spencer Tracy in
inherit the wind now bio Dean and the
winner is
when Miss gossin handed me this she very
graciously said so will earned and that
was a lovely thing to say I want to
needless to say I want to thank all the
members of the Academy who expressed
this kind of confidence in voting for me
and right now I feel so happy but I want
to thank all the members of the Academy
who did not vote for thank you all very
much